for the non-homogeneous system of
equations which means that for your
right-hand side at least one of B 1 B 2
B n is nonzero let's see how to solve
this so the general matrix
representation is ax equals B so pre
multiply it by a inverse so a inverse
times a times X equals a inverse times B
you have to do the operation on both
sides of the equation to keep the
relation the same and provided a inverse
exists then you will recognize this part
a inverse times a as the identity matrix
of order N equals a inverse times B and
any matrix multiplied by identity is
just itself so that gives us the
solution inverse times B
provided in her success so that is
adjoint of a so this is the method to
find the solution of a set of linear
equations in n unknowns now there are
some special cases so this thing works
fine if the determinant is nonzero now
what happens if the determinant is zero
so the special case if determinant is
zero look at the numerator of this
expression if adjoint of a times B if
this product is not zero the system of
equations this whole system of equations
is inconsistent and it has no solution
but if the numerator is also zero in
addition to the denominator being zero
then the system is consistent and it has
an infinite number of solutions okay so
this is one way using matrix operations
to solve a system of simultaneous linear
equations a second way is using
determinants or what is known as
Kramer's rule
for the same system of the questions ax
equals B the solution for each unknown
variable is given as X I equals 1 over
determinant of a times this and then
observe this carefully find the ith
column of the determinant so a1 I
replace it by b1 a2 I replace it by b2
yeah so this is a substitution operation
you don't keep the original term a1 I
ate Y and so on keep replacing this by
the elements of the right-hand side BN
and then the rest of the determinant
stays the same all the way up to a 1 and
a 2 n a and then
so this this whole operation we can
write it in shorthand as AI over a where
the determinant AI basically means that
you're substituting the ithe column of
the determinant by the right-hand side
for the elements of matrix B and this is
known as Kramer's rule in reality these
two are identical if you care to write
this whole thing down symbolically you
can show that this works out to be this
exactly so each element of this X will
work out to be adjoint of a over
determinant of a times matrix P which is
work out to be this now again what
happens if the denominator is zero so a
special case if a equals zero well again
look at the numerator if any of the
numerators is also zero inconsistent set
of equations there is no solution
I'm sorry if any of the difference in
the numerator is nonzero it is
inconsistent if all AI is are 0 for all
I the system is consistent and it has
infinite solutions
so we have looked at two methods to how
to solve a system of simultaneous linear
equations and n unknowns for the
non-homogeneous case which means that at
least one of the elements of your right
hand side the B matrix is nonzero now
the only thing to look at that is
remaining is the homogeneous system
which means that every single one of the
right-hand side is zero again we can
look at it using this method for example
if the determinant of a is nonzero there
is only a trivial solution which means
every single variable X 1 X 2 is 0 what
if the determinant is 0 and there is an
infinite number of solutions so these
are the two general methods to find out
the values of the unknown variables X 1
X 2 all the way to xn and so let's take
a solid example to better understand how
to work these methods
so let's say solve this system of
equations
we have x plus 7y minus 3z equals 25 y
plus z equals -3 + 3 x - 6 y plus 2z
equals 0 now as soon as you have a set
of equations given to you there are a
few things to check so first of all how
many unknowns so XYZ three unknowns and
you have three equations and three
unknowns so the number of equations is
equal to the number of unknowns now the
right-hand part of this set of equations
11 minus 3 0 so clearly it is not a
majnu system because you have these
nonzero elements on the right hand side
the next thing to check would be this
determinant so this part ax equals B so
let us first write it in that form so a
would be 1 7 minus 3 right here it's 0
times X 0 25 1 3 minus 6 2 this is your
a matrix times the variable matrix in
this case X Y Z
equals B which is 11 minus 3 0
so after writing it in this form ax
equals B the next thing to check is
whether this determinant a is 0 or not
so check with this calculation so 1 7
minus 3 0 25 1 3 minus 6 2 to be 1 times
56 I'm expanding by this column not that
if any column or row of the determinant
has one or more 0 elements it's always
easier to expand by that row or column
so that's why I'm choosing to expand by
this column instead of by any other row
or column so 1 times 50 plus 6 56 minus
0 times something the cofactor of this
element which we don't care
plus 3 times so 7 minus minus 75 so
82 so the value of the determinant of a
works out to be 302 which is not zero so
which means we can find out these
unknown values so because we are taking
this as a worked out example I want to
demonstrate this by both methods so
let's first try to find out the values
of x y and z by the matrix method so
using the matrix method well XY and Z
you need to find out as a inverse times
B using this definition and to do that
you first need to find out a inverse so
that is adjoint of a times B determinant
of a and for calculating the adjoint you
need to find out the cofactors of each
element of a and so let's take an
example recall c1 1 is minus 1 to the
power I plus J so 1 plus 1 and then you
block this block this off so 50 minus
minus 656
and so on I leave it as an exercise for
the reader to calculate each cofactor
and what you can show is adjoint of a is
basically the transpose of all the
cofactors of the elements of a works out
to be this 56 480 2 3 - 7 - 1 - 75
27 and 25 so a inverse is simply
adjoint of a divided by the determinant
of a so 1 over 3 or 2 times this whole
big matrix I'm not gonna write it again
and then once you have inverse you get
here unknown variables X Y Z is the
inverse times B I'll write it here 1
over T or 2 times 56 482 3 minus 7 minus
1 minus 75 27 25 times your right hand
side matrix which is 11 minus 3 0 and
you can do this calculation it works out
to be let's still keep this outside 1
over 3 or 2 and first do the
multiplications here you can show that
this works out to be 604 0 minus 906
which finally gives you
X is 2 y is 0 and Z is -3 so this is one
way to find out the values of x y and z